robbing so I cord our writer-director
felt that we have very little time to
actually put this up and and we were
supposed to be a couple that knew each
other very well and for a long time so
we didn't have any time to rehearse so
we took this quick little intimacy
course the two of us I mean lay it come
on come on you right now let's go really
okay come here where do we go right here
I'm gonna go right over here again okay
I made it over to you okay now just just
let it go right yes okay are you gonna
kiss me Oh see you're a little
uncomfortable see and so if we're just
able to breathe in each other's essence
right we'll be real close then after a
moment mhm
we can actually touch each other's
fingers and you get a sense of trusting
me and I you
mm-hmm and you're I I get a sense that
you're not as nervous now I can't do it
I can't do you really are touching me
yes I am and then it I'm not point goes
to this it goes at this well actually
goes from from not touching to back to
back we feel our each we feel our body
yeah yeah just be present and then we
touch our fingers just just to get a
sensory something sensual Charlie budget
is come on Charlie but how long was into
me and intimacy Korres what we did it we
did it in a day we took a crash course
none of it works but and ideally does
two or think it does it it helped propel
us to a point where we felt and Jennifer
and I were comfortable each other and
yeah one question did you let yourself
go there get giggles aside I could see
where I could though and more for just
and if I could see that